this is a dangerous moment for european
security
the number of russian forces is going up
the warning time for a possible attack
is going down
nato is not a threat to russia
but we must be prepared for the worst
while remaining strongly committed to
finding a political solution
the military
adaptation
uh
sends a clear signal
that that that russia has a choice they
can either choose a diplomatic solution
and we are ready to sit down but if they
choose confrontation they will pay a
high price
there will be economic sanctions
there will be
um
increased
nato military presence in eastern part
of the alliance to answer your question
directly about what i think is going on
in moscow and the calculations that are
being made there
i don't i honestly don't think a
decision has yet been taken but that
doesn't mean
that it is
uh
impossible that something absolutely
disastrous could happen very soon indeed
and our intelligence i'm afraid to to
to say remains
grim and we're seeing the massing of uh
of huge numbers of uh of uh tactical
battalion groups uh potential groups on
the on the borders of of ukraine uh 70
or more this is probably the most
dangerous moment uh i would say in the
in the course of the next few days in
what is the uh biggest security crisis
that uh europe has faced for decades and
you ask about whether uh where where it
won across the west on sanctions i think
increasingly actually we are at one
and
i think that i i congratulate uh olaf
schultz uh of germany on the way he's
been able to move towards
a tougher position on on nordstrom too
difficult though obviously that is uh
for germany and for for the german
economy uh i think that the uk has been
able to help to bring people together
with a with an automatic package of
sanctions that would hit uh
russian commercial uh strategic
strategic commercial interests
the tougher
those sanctions are the more automatic
they are the more chance we have of of
deterring what i think would be an
irrational response